i watched day shift starring jamie foxx
last night and i absolutely adored it
it's a great vampire movie but it made
me think one of my top three vampire
movies of all time
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
first of all i'm going to say day shift
a great movie it's why i love vampire
films it doesn't take itself too
seriously it's a comedy at times it's
got some brilliant gore in it which
always amuses me it respects the vampire
lore while adding a few new twists i
love for example there's a fight scene
at the start bit of a spoiler here but
he's fighting an old woman that's a
vampire obviously not just punching an
old woman in the face that would have
been much of a movie
um but you can see the fight in the
mirror and in the mirror it's just the
pajamas of the the woman's wearing you
can't see the reflection the little
things like that great special effects
that i absolutely adore so you haven't
seen dayshift with jamie foxx on netflix
yet please go watch it it's great and
before i get into my top three vampire
movies of all time i gotta give a couple
of honorable mentions
blade with wesley snipes and then blade
trinity actually i i equally adore both
those movies was just brilliant it's a
balls out action movie it's not
particularly clever in ways but it's
just a great movie
um
it is very grown up in places
it's very silly in other places and the
whole fight scene at the end
[Music]
it's just great i love it and it makes
you want to go and punch a vampire in
the face it's a brilliant film i
absolutely love it
um underworld very similarly
vampires and werewolves kate beckinsdale
insanely sexy throughout
just a brilliant movie rise of the
likens was also absolutely brilliant um
really great special effect i love the
bit where she steps off the tower and
just the hero land and then just walks
it's just really seriously cool and the
second and third ones were awful but
really ignore that um it's just the
first one was a great movie and really
actually
you know copied sort of it it was like
the matrix with werewolves i have no
problem with that but yeah just a great
film
um fright night 2011 version gets my an
honorable mention basically because
david tennant's in it and david tennant
is brilliant in it now i love the
original but the 2011 version was just
great and if you haven't seen it please
go give it a watch this one i'm going to
get some hate text for people are going
to go jay have you lost your freaking
mind what are you talking about
but abraham lincoln
vampire hunter
didn't make my top three but i actually
do love this film
um it's quite funny in places it doesn't
take itself too seriously because how
can it it's about abraham lincoln
vampire hunter it's based on a series of
very dark comic books and actually it's
just really really good if you haven't
seen it don't listen to the haters
because it did bomb and it did
did no business at the box office but
don't listen haters go watch it it's
actually
not a bad film you have to turn your
brain off a little bit but about you
after for all great movies
by the way if you are new to channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you are enjoying the content please
consider hitting the join button because
that really helps us out so my top three
i'm starting off with a big hitter the
lost boys
you don't want to miss this
joel schumacher's 1987 take on the
vampire movie was game changing nobody
really seen a vampire movie like that
before it was very much set in its time
it's like along the lines of sort of
like the breakfast club and other movies
in style in some ways
you know there was team angst and it was
a movie basically made for teenagers but
nobody had ever quite seen a vampire
movie done that way before it's been
copied lots of times since you could
argue actually the buffy the vampire
slayer was heavily inspired by this
movie
don't ever invite a vampire into your
house you silly boy it renders you
powerless
did you know that
of course
everyone knows that and i just have to
say that it thoroughly deserves to be in
my top three because akifa sutherland is
great in it all the other actors are
great in it there's there are comedy
elements in it there are bits in it that
are kind of silly whether but there are
bits in it that are actually very
terrifying as well it has all the bits
that make a great vampire movie for me
i'm going to tell you now though that
none of the films on my list are
particularly serious vampire movies and
none of them are going to be twilight
either
i don't particularly enjoy the series
vampire movies bram stoker's dracula is
a great movie but it is very very heavy
and very serious i prefer the movies
that have a bit of fun to them so number
two on my list
john carpenter's vampires
now james woods
is one of those actors that i absolutely
adore i don't like his politics but i do
like him as an actor he did this film
with a
boxing which i can't remember the name
of but it's a great movie
[Music]
james wood's character jack crow is
thoroughly dislikable almost every
character in the movie is thoroughly
dislikable
there is no it is a proper anti-hero
sort of character
you're not supposed like him they drink
they do drugs they do prostitutes they
do all sorts of things they're not nice
people they're not really doing this
because they
are trying to save anyone's life they're
doing it because they hate vampires or
they want money
so
again it's a completely different twist
on the vampire genre john carpenter for
me who's the director did an amazing job
he completely twisted the whole fat
helsink sort of character idea on its
head
there's some brilliant gore
um i remember one character gets his
head pulled off another character gets
cut in half with his hand and they are
it's just it's just absolutely
phenomenal the first time i watched it i
knew nothing about it i sat there and
watched it and [ __ ] and i watched it
again the next day
it's terrifying in places it's funny in
places and it just
twists the whole idea of what a vampire
movie should be completely up in knots
i'm going
[Music]
i absolutely adore this movie and i
really struggled not putting it in at
number one
another film that deserves a quick
mention is daybreakers now i actually
found the film quite disappointing a
little boring but i did think that the
idea was very very clever
but at number one is a brilliantly
clever movie one that completely blew my
mind when i saw it from dustil thorne
quentin tarantino completely played up
to quentin tarantino style in this movie
for the first half you just think it's
another tarantino movie
we gotta get our ashes into mexico
tonight and carlos is going to meet us
there at the rendezvous tomorrow morning
well now he and
his boys both of all of them are going
to escort us
to el rey
where's a woman
and then it turns into the bloodbath of
a vampire movie directed by robert
rodriguez that we now love to this day
i don't remember
it spawned a tv series that was rubbish
and a couple of movies that were also
rubbish but the original was fantastic
incredibly clever and george clooney
again well it made his career we also
got to see selma hayek for the first
time
with a snake
quite like that
[Music]
i love this movie because again it's got
the silliness
it's got the fun
it's got the violence and it's in places
terrifying it was again a twist on the
vampire movie that we've never seen
before and added to the lore of the
vampires i love the bit at the end where
you come away and you can see that it's
the temple pyramid with all the trucks
it had elements in this movie that were
very very clever
it was an astonishingly well put
together film
it was a film that knew exactly what it
was and played up to it it was a film
that knew quentin tarantino would be in
it and played up to that
just a brilliantly clever movie that
twists you all over the place several
times you never know what's coming next
and for me it's just a perfect vampire
film
so guys tell me what you think what are
your top three vampire movies i'd love
to know get in the comments and if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification it
really helps us out also you can become
a fully fledged side tracker hit the
join button as always guys please stay
safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you